foreign
I want to present to you the Bridgetown
initiative it's a pragmatic ambitious
plan to save the world that's been
gaining a surprising traction
I'm going to start with a who move to
the what and where we are
I came late to climb it I wasn't a
skeptic I'm an economist we believe that
if we don't value something well enough
we tend to over consume it I believe
that I just wasn't seized by a
compulsion to do something about it
myself until September the 18th 2017.
I was sitting in the departure Lounge at
JFK waiting to go home to Bridgetown
Barbados
nursing a coffee and my phone buzzes
and it's mere Amor Motley college friend
and then leader of the opposition of
Barbados
go to Dominica now she says on
neighboring Island they've just been
smashed by Hurricane Maria
they gave all the help they can get time
for you to step into the shoes of that
previous generation of influential
development economists just like your
dad
she's compassionate super smart and
obviously a good politician because I am
on a un relief plane the next day doing
a hairpin turn to land on the emergency
airstrip in Dominica
the Pilot's last mission was dodging
missiles in Syria so I'm feeling fairly
safe I have my head wedged against the
window transfix of what's below
a hurricane can release the energy of 10
000 nuclear bombs and below me is a
nuclear Wasteland pointing up towards me
are a million thin white sticks takes me
a moment to realize their trees stripped
bare of all branches leaves and bark
when we land I'm assaulted by the smell
of burning and decomposition and
something else it takes me a while
longer to work out I'm on a tropical
island normally teeming with birds and
insects and and color
in deathly monochrome silence
the birds have gone the land is emptied
later dominica's prime minister
Roosevelt scaret says Dominicans have
lost everything money can buy in four
hours
the government's job was to make them
feel that what was left was the valuable
stuff Community Family Hope and to help
them repair because if despair set in
then a bad bad situation would get worse
early on I work out that the way to get
recovery funds flowing is to make
Dominica Mata to the world so Dominica
declares they will rebuild as the
world's first climate resilient Nation
they dust themselves off stand tall and
Resolute and invite the world's experts
in turns out the Dominicans have the
real insights we we made a list of all
the things they had to do in the
immediate aftermath of the disaster and
asked what will they have to do now so
they wouldn't have to do that next time
around
and the answers kept on heading higher
energy and health resilient systems
National and Regional food security and
then the global because there's no real
alternative to halting climate change
and that's why the world's biggest plan
the bridge child initiative comes partly
from the world's smallest countries
and it actually makes even more sense to
that because tropical places are where
temperatures droughts and sea levels
will rise to their highest most extreme
levels we are the canaries in the mine
and we can see there's no point gasping
for air for ourselves we have to save
the mind and we can also see what's
getting in the way because once most
people believe climate change is here
and happening and urgent they also
believe someone else should be doing
more about it
rich countries are electrifying shifting
reducing so much so that the majority of
greenhouse gas emissions 63 and climbing
are now coming from developing countries
there is now no Pathway to avoid the
world's destabilizing planetary systems
without the green transformation of
developing countries the rich say to the
poor you need to ban emissions tax
carbon shift into Renewables and get
with the program
but that would slow the growth of
developing countries
they'd have to borrow a lot at very high
interest rates to invest in the new
decommission the old find new jobs for
old coal miners and more and why should
they the rich cause global warming
they're responsible for 70 of the stock
of greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
for using up sixty percent of the
world's carbon budget you can't scoff
sixty percent of the cake and then say
afterwards well we all need to cut back
now
don't don't cement inequality
don't cement inequality to poor say send
Aid
the problem is that all of the aid in
the world will not fund 1 12 of the
green transformation in developing
countries and which country governments
are not getting elected to send money to
foreigners they're getting elected to
deport foreigners
so we're stuck staring at each other
pointing fingers
once the world Burns
I figured that the way to break this
impasse
is if we stop only looking at ourselves
and make the cost of resilience so cheap
the flow of Finance after a disaster so
immediate
the green transformational developing
countries so profitable that we turn
reluctance into a scramble there's no
extra time we're on countdown and that
is the essence of the Bridgetown
initiative
during covid and the global financial
crisis rich countries purchased 24
trillion dollars of bonds to pump their
economy
If instead they'd purchased 24 trillion
dollars of bonds that Finance renewable
energies we'd have had the same economic
impact and be halfway to holding climate
change already and we would have reduced
our inflationary dependence on oil and
coal all within 12 years the power of
what we can do when it matters to us is
unlimited so here's the financing plan
that does not rely on the altruism of
financiers and insurers is not based on
some unproven tech
and there's not skirt around our common
but different responsibilities
picture three buckets
small medium and large
the smallest is actually the hardest to
fund it's all of those things that don't
generate any savings or profits it's
rebuilding the homes of low-income
families that have been washed away by
climate event it's rebuilding recovering
their their livelihoods their clinics
their schools and climate change
remember is the increasing certainty of
rising losses it's uninsurable so we
need new sources of Public Finance we
need new emission taxes on oil and coal
and methane at the motley macron Summit
in June in Paris we made some progress
towards taxing Emissions on the shipping
industry we need more and we need a
small financial transaction tax like the
one you don't even realize you're paying
today that covers the cost of the US sec
and energy and finance consumption is
slanted to the rich
the second bucket is for those things
that don't generate revenues but
generates immediate savings
if I invest a dollar of borrowed money
on stronger sea walls more muscular
flood defenses more resilient Health
Systems I saved several dollars so we
need the International multilateral
Development Banks like the World Bank to
lend three times more on the sustainable
development goals and to make that debt
cheap by making it longer and lower cost
they can get halfway there by using the
resources they already have they're very
conservative and the other half they
need rich countries to put in a little
bit more Capital now some people
criticize me for saying why are you
going for cheap loans rather than grants
and I say if you found a trillion dollar
stuff behind a sofa then okay but grants
will never be enough and so let's focus
of Grants on those things that can't be
funded any other way because there's no
savings and profits
the final bucket the biggest bucket is
for those things for which there is a
Revenue tax but before I go to that on
the second bucket at Paris at the motley
macron Summit we got a commitment of an
extra 20 billion dollars of lending a
year a start
the third bucket the biggest Revenue
solar Farms a wind turbines they make
money whilst reducing greenhouse gases
in the rich countries 81 of that is
funded by the private sector if we want
developing countries to move faster than
rich countries do then we want those
investors to go to the developing World
they don't today because of the high
cost of guaranteeing their returns
against the fluctuation of currencies
however history shows that an
international agency capitalized by Rich
countries that takes a diversified view
across time and countries can lower the
cost without losing money and buy enough
to unblock the flow of Investments and a
small group of countries have agreed to
move on a pilot this year
three buckets small one for costs middle
one for savings big one for revenues
there are a couple things we also need
to do that doesn't cost money we need
Barbados style pause Clauses in all debt
instruments when a disaster hits you're
suspend your interest payments and debt
repayments are suspended for two years
added back on till uh later when you can
afford it it will release billions of
dollars and reshape the financial system
and as prime minister Motley says if we
want these institutions of a setup in
the colonial era if you want to trust
them to save the world then the people
they serve cannot be invisible in the
halls of power
so the impasse is cracking
I got all that playing to Dominica
because of my dad not because of his
profession but because he was a dad I
remember asking him once when I was
being asked to join an unpopular cause
that was going to hurt my career and I
was half hoping he would say no son
that's silly
instead he said gently Avi you've got to
be a player in this life so here I am
please join us
foreign